hey how hard was it uh becoming such a
famous model
and you know being at the top you know
the top really i mean you were doing all
the huge magazines in the future you
were one of the big models of all time
and
i have to think that it looks so
glamorous and fun but it probably wasn't
all the time was it
well first of all i have to say i do not
consider myself a success as a model
me you know i consider like linda
christie naomi and cindy and claudia and
stephanie that was the success but you
were a big model
i was with them like in the same stuff
as them but i was never that tear in my
opinion well you don't have to compare
yourself but
right you don't have to compare yourself
to them but you could say i had a lot of
success in modeling
okay yeah that's a good point okay yes
correct i had a lot of success as as
modeling and to be honest
i wish
i would have oh god don't
kill me or judge me i was one of those
girls that was pretty but didn't know
she was pretty no but that's the best
that's the best kind
oh you sweet thing like i look back at
those things now
and i look at finley and you know my
daughters and i'm like oh my god y'all
are so stunning and i look at those you
know people send me stuff on social
media all the time and i look at the
shoots that i did and the places that i
mean like
i was on the great wall of china with
valentino
there you go right i mean you can't make
that up that's amazing i was on the
concord with kate moss and sting and i
mean all of that stuff what i just
yes that's a power sting how is
sting
i'll tell you when i met him because i
mean oh my god how much do you love that
guy when i met him it was in like some
nightclub and he clearly was not
interested in like meeting you know
fangirling models or whatever and i
totally respected that but it was just
like
what you know because one of my friends
was like his biggest fan he's like why
get out of here and then like and i was
just like oh
and then that was kind of it which it's
fine but you know you you expect him to
be like some profound like you know
so you weren't stung you weren't stung
i was not stuck yeah because you i
didn't expect him to be like us
right right right but flying
flying on the concord i mean were these
great experiences because i always hear
a lot of stuff about
modeling and your agents are always like
oh um katie you need to lose 10 pounds
or you need to do this and it's it's
very hard and it could be and a lot of
people go through a lot of [ __ ] and i'm
just wondering if you ever had to go
through that stuff
i never heard any of that kind of stuff
but i think that's because that was just
how i was naturally
um
but you know yeah we i definitely i had
a girlfriend that died of an eating
disorder i had
you know um
you know yeah i mean but i think
i don't know i just i just wish like
when i look back on my life
i wish i would have appreciated it more
when i was in it
at all don't we all it's like you look
at these moments in these pictures and
you're like i don't remember having
as great of a time as
i remember maybe because i wasn't as
present my problem is i'm not as present
it's hard for me to be present i'm
always
my mind just is going a million miles an
hour are you able to do that now and
experience things and kind of go i'm
blessed i'm grateful look at this moment
take it in are you able to do that more
well yeah cause now i'm medicated